Florida malaria cases are spreading and
this is a problem for Ron DeSantis now
you might say David six cases of malaria
spread by mosquitoes why is it a problem
for DeSantis ordinarily it wouldn't be
but there are two positions that
DeSantis has left open that relate
specifically to preventing the
transmission of disease I don't even
believe for a second that were those two
positions filled these six cases of
malaria wouldn't currently be in Florida
but when you're trying to make the case
that you're running the state the right
way and then there's something we
haven't seen in a long time the spread
of malaria in your state and we find out
two relevant positions have been left
open it looks very bad